hi it's my birthday hooray it's actually
tomorrow
hooray I'm turning 27 gray someone told
me I'm almost 30 right
I'm dying it's actually very weird to
think that when I started this whole
YouTube thing I was actually 22 years
old and now look at me what the hell
happened
either way I'm old it doesn't matter but
I just got back from VidCon and it was
an amazing time I got to meet so many
other youtubers and some of my favorite
youtubers that I haven't gotten to meet
in the past like boogie I've been
watching boogie2988 if you didn't know
for a long long time when he's been a
big source of inspiration and we got him
like this this circular ass-kissing
contest to be like no you inspire me and
then he was like no you inspire me and
I'm like no you you inspire me you
he's like you did bang you
inspire me so it's just blends of that
if you haven't checked out his
channel I'll put a link in the
description below he has a cool cool guy
you should definitely check his videos
if you had it in the past and then of
course you know I got to hang out with
the youtubers that I've known for a long
time Jack was there you know Ryan and
Matt were there a whole bunch of other
youtubers that I've met and password
there and the problem is like with most
conventions that I go to I get so caught
up in being there and doing the things
while I'm there that I totally forget to
actually take pictures and record video
because I'm a douchebag and I forget to
actually post stuff out for you guys so
in all honesty I know a lot of you guys
wanted to see a collab with me and Jack
I forgot to do that it wasn't enough
time I was busy so I'll just have to
invite him out to LA again sometime in
the future
along with Wade and Bob Bob needs to
come to LA please tweet at Bob tell him
to come to LA he's done with school
I need him look miss him poor bull that
way too I guess wait come along - but I
miss those guys they weren't at VidCon
and actually a big con I had a pan
there and they wanted to stick me in the
giant room they had this room with like
seating for 4,500 people it's the
biggest room in the place and they told
me that I would easily fill out the
place and that was intimidating to me
because I was doing the panel by myself
which I've never done a panel just by
myself and they had an alternative which
was a much smaller room it was about a
500 person room and it was a more
intimate environment I mean even 500
people it's still a lot of people but
something smaller scale like that
appeals to me more because I'm able to
actually interact with people and I'm
able to actually talk with people and
it's not like you're watching me on
these weird big projectors I mean next
year I'll do it because I heard that a
lot of people were very disappointed
that they didn't get into the panel and
it's something that I have to
acknowledge the fact that there are so
many people out there that want to see
me and when I go to these conventions it
is intimidating to see how many people
want to meet me and security was a big
concern this year and it went very well
there was no incidents as far as I know
there may have been small incidents here
and there but it went relatively
smoothly from Maya there was actually
this one moment where myself
Jack Emma blackery and comics story and
we're doing an event on the maker stage
and it was really fun it went totally
well some of you saw it live streamed
and we're playing funemployed but after
it was over it was the only time that we
were a little scared because as you know
like there's a lot of people at VidCon
there's just so many people densely
packed on the VidCon floor and there
were so many people crowding the room
the booth that as soon as we got done we
literally had nowhere to go we were
trying to get backstage but it's like we
stepped into the zombie horde not
comparing you guys some bees or a now
I'm an now but not comparing you
guys a zombies but it's just like so
many people wanted selfies that we were
just getting phones shoved in our faces
and we were going to jostle it around
and I mean it's flattering in a way that
so many people want to meet us but it's
scary when there's a hundred people at
once trying very desperately to get a
picture so we were just trying to get
backstage so we can go to another
because at vidcon like all of us
creators are booked very tightly we're
going from one event to another to
another to another and then we get like
an hour break for a meal and then
another and another and another and it
was just very intimidating because
security was so beefed up we had like
four big burly security guards and even
they're like holy these kids got
German apparently Santa Claus was our
bodyguard this year but it was just it
was the only moment where it's ever been
intimidating and I think that's just
because it's VidCon and VidCon you know
you guys who go there are much more
intense it's like the fan central thing
so of course there's so many super fans
there whereas if you go to pax you know
it's gamers it's chill it's whatever you
know where they're mostly there for the
video games and not mostly there for us
but VidCon is just like only the people
that are there so it gets a little
intense sometimes but the other thing
that happened at VidCon was there were
three separate families at VidCon that
wanted to meet me from the make-a-wish
Foundation and that's a huge honor like
people at PAX came to meet me from the
make-a-wish Foundation I've done
make-a-wish stuff before it's a complete
honor to be able to walk in that room
and meet people who have gone through so
much struggle and it was really like
both a heartwarming and a heartbreaking
experience to be able to talk to these
families and I got I got about we were
booked so tight like I said that I got
about half hour each with each of these
families just to be able to sit down and
talk and it was a great time because I
walked into the first family and it was
it was like they were very tearful and
they were so excited to see me and I was
just like hey how's it going oh gosh
don't cry I'm normal I swear I'm weird
but I'm normal and and by the end of the
conversation you know I hope they
realized that I'm just a normal guy
I hope they realized that I very closely
to these experiences that they have gone
through and that you know really really
I do care about their well-being and I
care about them and I care that they
watch my videos to get them through
these tough surgeries you know
chemotherapy that some of them have to
go through
these harsh experiences that children
should not have to deal with but they do
I'm glad that my videos can help out in
any way so it was a huge honor and
actually I recorded a few videos with
each of them so here they are in all
their glory
hey guys up here with the make-a-wish
Foundation with Katie and her family the
Clemens family so just wanted to say hi
they got to get going we just wrapped up
our meeting but I wanted to record this
and say thank you for me I did I let me
do the video in charge here
hi guys welcome to my vlog not Nathan's
there
he's intruding that's why you're
standing in the shade and I'm
illuminated nice to meet you I'm here
with him and his family we just wrapped
up our little meeting here at VidCon and
I'm trying to get everyone but they're
so spread apart that's God he works he
works for make-a-wish he doesn't want to
be on camera but he's gonna be on care
all right but anyway so I'm just saying
goodbye right now but uh say hi do
Nathan and his family okay hi markiplier
here with another make-a-wish family
from VidCon this is Tyler that's Kathy
that's Jessica we're here to say what we
do I told him the secret to YouTube's
success and it's all dick jokes but that
wasn't a joke that was just saying the
big dicks the Thank You Tyler thank you
everybody for watching we'll see you
later bye sweep sweep
bye those Tyler at the end there he
really got me Tyler really understood me
and he's gonna start a YouTube channel
pretty soon that guy's funny mostly just
because the whole time I was there he
was telling dick jokes and that is like
oh that warms my buck
laughing dick job but it was an awesome
time at VidCon was a great time so thank
you everybody who came out to meet me
and I'm sorry if some people wanted to
meet me and couldn't it was crazy there
there were so many people there were so
many creators so many fans and we were
booked so tight like if there's only one
of us each individually there's only one
of us creators and there's so many of
you guys we're trying to spread the love
but thank you everybody
who did and thank you everybody who went
to VidCon to me not only me but all the
other creators there and thank you for
all the birthday wishes I don't need any
presence it's okay I'm perfectly fine
thank you for all the well wishes and I
will do something I'll stick a candle in
one slice of cheesecake and I will eat
it and that will be my celebration so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye